[Music]
most people assume or at the very least
hope that their governments are doing
the right thing but can you take this
now down to the personal level in the
community level
you know from as simple as washing hands
to just other techniques people should
be doing in their daily lives right now
so the first message is wash your hands
a lot touch your face less that's the
thing everybody can do now because we're
in a pandemic state we have to think
about social distancing and that's gonna
be a little bit different for every
person depending on what's essential to
them and what's not essential
starting with people who are older or
who have medical problems they need to
start thinking about their interactions
with other people and trying to limit
their risk because that's what we're
really worried about here that's what
this is all designed to help them
because if they end up getting sick in
large numbers we will crash our whole US
healthcare system because we don't have
the capacity to deal with that many sick
people such as what's going on in Italy
other individuals who are lower risk you
have to think about what you're doing
how you can minimize your time minimize
your contacts without completely
destroying your quality of life you
might there's you know there's some
variation on what people can and can't
do right now we're seeing governors
close bars and restaurants and I think
that's something that you're going to
see more of because there's too much
social interaction going on in those
types of places and they end up being a
nexus for the spread of the virus but I
do think that just being common common
sense you know if you're going to the
gym go at times where there's not that
not peak hours maybe order out instead
of think order takeout instead of
sitting in a restaurant maybe in mass
gatherings are basically being banned
everywhere because of their their risk
so that's not an issue to think about
anymore but it's that type of thing that
you're gonna have to do at least for a
period of two weeks and maybe longer to
see if we can actually blunt them
respond blunt the curve basically or
flatten it out because we don't want to
exceed hospital capacity so that the
idea is let's slow the number of the
rate of infection so that they're coming
at a slower clip to the hospital so that
they don't get overwhelmed because we're
really nervous about that that's the
biggest that's the biggest in the
linchpin in our responses so I know that
you talked about the differences that
Italy has just in terms of the
demographics and population but I hear a
lot of people saying oh we're just two
weeks behind Italy do you think that
that's a fair estimation
if you look at the numbers we we have a
case count around what Italy had two
weeks before so I think it is something
that people are saying with some
evidence behind it I think we're gonna
start to know if we're gonna follow this
Italian type of model or we're gonna
have more of a South Korean outbreak but
it's increasing looking like it might be
a little bit of a hybrid between them
because we were not as quick with
testing mild cases and isolating them as
South Korea was yeah can you talk about
flattening the curve that seems to be
the phrase that everybody's talking
about we're seeing a lot of images on
Twitter sure sure so what we're talking
about here's the epidemic curve so think
of it like a bell curve you have a peak
in cases and then they go they peak and
they come down well we're trying and we
have a line here where hospital capacity
is you want to keep your curve below
hospital capacity even if it means you
have the same amount of cases but you
flatten it out so you never exceed
hospital capacity so that's what we're
trying to do we know that we can't
contain this virus but can we slow the
accumulation of cases to a rate that's
manageable by hospitals that's what
flattening the curve is so you don't
have this big peak you kind of have a
rolling peak that's not as not as huge
of a spike and that's the that's kind of
the strategy being pursued by many
different countries now in order to
preserve our hospitals where are guys
like you turning for sensible
information I see online that seems to
be the number one thing just for the
average person is we live in a strange
time where people don't trust our
institutions the way they used to you
know there's always a lot of noise on
social media I mean where are you
getting actual information where where
should we point people to besides you
know interviews like this and and things
like that so obviously they're you know
if you're an infectious disease person
you kind of have your own sources that
might not be suitable for for people in
the general public but there are good
sources the CDC is actually a very good
site there's a lot of stuff on there
that you can use that's actually vetted
and there's guidance and lots of
different types of all types of
different scenarios you could imagine I
think I would also make sure that people
are looking at their local and state
health department web sites because if
something happens to them it's gonna be
local you need to know what's going on
locally and what the plant plans are
there as well and then I would say for
science stuff I recommend stat news the
most at use is owned by the Boston Globe
it's probably the best scientific
reporting in the in the world that's
where I look at that every day and
there's another group called CID raps
CIDR ap which is at the University of
Minnesota that's the Center for
infectious disease research and policy
they also
very good news articles that are easily
digestible by the public and have a lot
of really great factual information
there pameron were obviously in some
unchartered territory with coronavirus
and our plan here is to help you make as
much sense of the situation and a non
alarmist fashion as possible if you're
looking for reliable information from
experts on the front lines of the
pandemic check out our coronavirus
playlist which will keep adding updates
- right over here and to get notified of
all future videos be sure to subscribe